[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est complètement
il faudrait que tu nous fasses ton
nouveau son qui est très très fort
j'appelle moi qui veut dire bien sûr en
anglais le parapluie
[Rires]
non c'est vrai c'est le son là
elle vient nous faire on est une bombe
atomique woman pense à toi Gilles un
coup de bien ce qu'elle dit tu vas voir
que à mon avis elle a pensé à toi c'est
parti c'est marrant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est trop sûr de lui donc j'ai des
glaçons
[Musique]
toi et moi c'est plein d'amour plein
d'amour et plein d'amour et toi et moi
c'est pour toujours et pour toujours et
pour toujours
[Musique]
avec toi chaque jour
si on me dit que je t'aime je vous
je voudrais pas que je le presse je le
presse je le presse et votre avec moi il
me dit que le temps presse est le temps
presse
si ça te déconne
faut pas précipiter sinon
[Musique]
toujours mais pour toujours et pour
toujours
[Musique]
ça c'est le mal je sais que vous pourrez
avec toi chaque jour
de magique je t'aime j'avoue
[Musique]
pourquoi je serai là où on manque je
serai de mon mal romane woman laisse-moi
être woman pourquoi je sais l'amour
qu'il te faut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]